the night of august 3rd
1976 started off peacefully
priscilla davis and stan farr were
coming back from a night out with their
friends
and pulling up to her fort worth mansion
but as soon as priscilla stepped into
her kitchen she came face to face with a
man dressed entirely in black and
wearing a woman's wig
the man only said hi before shooting her
in the chest
[Music]
the shooter would ultimately leave two
dead and one paralyzed that night
yet somehow priscilla survived
and when it came time to identify the
shooter priscilla had no doubt in her
mind
her estranged husband colin davis wasn't
just the prime suspect
but an heir to one of america's
wealthiest families
and he was being charged with capital
murder at the time
he was reported to be america's richest
murder defendant ever
davis hi mr davis it's noah kersh from
forbes calling you back
as you may have guessed i'm writing a
story here just kind of retelling the
story of priscilla
whose idea to drag this up
[Music]
cullen's father's name was kenneth davis
but he went by stinky
and he ran this firm called ken davis
industries which was worth tens of
millions of dollars if not more
ken davis ended up passing the firm down
to three of his sons
one of whom was cullen
priscilla wilborn came from a really
different background she came from a
blue collar town in texas
and she never knew her father cullen's
affair with priscilla
started at their country club but
quickly progressed into something
serious
each got divorced from their current
partners it was cullen's first divorce
and priscilla's second cullen and
priscilla tied the knot on august 29th
1968 the very day that cullen's father
died
cullen immediately began building their
19 000 square foot dream home
that he would share with priscilla for a
number of years until priscilla decided
to end the marriage in 1974.
that july on her 33rd birthday she filed
for divorce
and a day after that cullen found
himself forced off of his own property
he was court-ordered not to come on or
around the mansion
or its 181-acre grounds until their
divorce was finalized
it was a messy time two years passed
since the filing
and there was still no resolution by
this time
priscilla had a new boyfriend stan farr
who lived with her in the very mansion
from which cullen was banned
naturally as soon as she was shot
priscilla screamed really loudly
which alerted her lover as she called
him this guy
stan farr who was like six foot five and
he sprinted towards the kitchen at which
point he encountered the shooter
who shot and killed him
[Music]
by coincidence just as the shooting
happened two of priscilla's friends
pulled into the driveway
and the shooter went outside and shot
one of them in the spine and paralyzed
him
police arrived at the chaotic scene of
the crime
first responders rushed priscilla and
bubba gavrill who was also shot
to the hospital priscilla despite
bleeding from her gunshot wound
was able to identify the shooter she
said it was her estranged husband
cullen davis when she arrived at the
hospital
she found out her 12 year old daughter
andrea wilborn
had also been killed
police issued an all-points bulletin for
cullen and he was arrested at his new
girlfriend's home
authorities found five weapons in the
trunk of his car
but none of them matched the murder
weapon
cullen was first charged over andrea's
murder and though the evidence in that
case
was largely circumstantial he faced a
possible death sentence
he hired one of the top trial lawyers in
the country richard racehorse haynes
to defend him in court in the murder of
12 year old andrea
haynes attacked priscilla's reputation
and undermined her credibility
the trial went on for three months and
cullen was found
not guilty decades after the trial it
came to light that
a member of cohen's defense team was
paying someone in the district
attorney's office
five thousand dollars every single month
to give intel on the prosecution
strategy
it was a huge amount of money back then
and it's completely possible
that it altered the course of that trial
nine months later one of cullen's
friends approached the fbi
saying that cullen had wanted him to
hire a hitman to kill 15 people
including priscilla and the judge was
presiding over their divorce
federal agents set up a sting operation
to get him to admit to soliciting a hit
man
again he hired racehorse haynes and
again he was found not guilty
cullen got married once again and
priscilla moved to dallas
where she spent five years living with
greg brown
yeah how do you say greg brown in one or
two words
greg brown is one of priscilla's closest
friends from later in life and
actually wrote a book about their
relationship
does that work i mean they were lovers
too
technically it's pretty complicated
listen i moved in with priscilla i was
she was 54. she had been the most
glamorous
woman living the largest mansion with
the richest man
we were both heavy drinkers i was gay
but it was a fun fun
life being her lover priscilla kept
calling in court
you know this case just didn't go away
when
cullen was acquitted of the murder of
andrea and of
the hit job on the judge
[Music]
if you don't mind i'd like to ask you
about some of the controversial things
during that tumultuous period i know
there was an interview
where you talked about dee's cat
can you tell me about that incident
that was a priscilla's uh
daughter dee
that this obeyed something i told her to
do
and when i confronted her about it
she got alecky
and she was holding this kitten
brand new kitten and
i just grabbed it and threw it down
and it died
that's basically what happened
you sound like someone maybe who used to
get angry but over time has mellowed is
that fair
i didn't get that angry very often
throwing things or hitting people
but you could say that would be an
accurate statement
did you ever hit priscilla
she lied to me about something and
i didn't touch her i slapped her on my
face
that was the only time
so i i mean i assume your position still
is that you had nothing to do with the
shooting at the house
that's correct
who do you think could have done it
no possible idea
i think that her story's been forgotten
priscilla was the most vivacious
magnet that people were drawn to because
of both her glamour and her positive
energy she's been vilified of course
and she's thought of as the beautiful
blonde bombshell that was on the other
side of the tracks and as we know
that's how colin got off for the murder
of her child
[Music]
you